[Music]
country music is the worst genre of
music what do you think answer in the
comments below and suggest a prompt on
our kickstarter
we took off in the park he kept up a
conversation then it started getting
dark i gave him an invitation to my
apartment complex and it's kind of
complex my brother in the next room i
don't want to alarm him up i'm a sneaky
win
if you had to rank yourself against
others based on a specific trait
what would it say about how you see them
and how they see you
we brought together five rappers to rank
each other based on who they think is
the most talented then our followers
rearrange them based on who they think
is the most talented this is ranking
yo what up guys it's your boy digital
dab i'm a south korean artist residing
in la make sure to follow me on digital
dab x oh one more time make sure to
follow me on digital x dash
what's good i'm figgy baby don't forget
the baby
la based artist internationally tauren
my name is jason chu asian american
artist out here la let's get it let's go
y'all alpha patron african-american
artist hip-hop fusion i like to
incorporate different things
and i'm just excited to see y'all i'm
gianni from brooklyn
and i'm also excited it's performance
it's preparedness it's crafts
it's it's lyricism it's storytelling
it's range i mean eye contact your
ability to connect a lot of things music
evolves and i think nowadays it's more
about having fun i appreciate all types
of music
yeah
check
you had me kicked out of the whole city
and you never spoke on my behalf of show
pity the eight of us students were the
only victims in the school district
acting like they were ripped out of
eighth grade at 14 with me you made me
feel like a criminal i was a kid
you made me feel like a criminal i was a
kid
y'all that's why i never felt guilty for
what i did i take back every fake
apology my father couldn't speak to me
for weeks you made him believe i lost a
heart of me a drug lord a banger violent
juvenile lived in the room right across
from his now that's both sons mom and
dad you should really be thanking paul
for smoking me out cause i been hitting
up gang members to get me high before he
did took the blame to keep me safe while
we breathing stole my first aid so i
didn't get deep in didn't yell at me
after i ratted him out
never was hurt as everyone else he knew
that i was just a child keeping me safe
as much as he knew how i love you bro
bro
whoa
man that was beautiful i just love the
intention i love what you're talking
about and i like that you talking on
certain things without being preachy
but just sharing from from your heart so
i'm with them
[Music]
give me the c i'm reclining i got that
ja on me i'm flying
flying hey he's always dripping like a
hooper hey i've been feeling so cool
hey energy stay super huh what do i have
to do
[Music]
long legs
asian americans man they call us a model
minority but what are we the model for
why are we a minority in this country
how we treated model in our wallets they
thinking we got commas really in back
pockets we carrying deep traumas hang
tight is by our own trials is seen as
outsiders used to redline us time called
us out whiten the white scholars drove a
divide between us and the black brothers
you got admitted to dominant white
college still you ain't valid for most
of those white collars
southeast asian dark cousins drive down
the streets police radio buzzing
gaslighted to thinking we made progress
still they killed christian hall said
nothing
not a model not a monolith yeah i'm not
a pawn for your politics yeah i learned
from gandhi and dr king if this system
don't bring peace we must abolish it hey
[Music]
all right
you know you're standing up for us for
minorities we need to do that more when
people talk about politics he's like man
i feel sad after this but i'm like
okay yeah there's hope and i loved how
you had those vocals at the chorus it
really illustrated that well
yeah
uh
i was lost and i needed some directions
hard times i didn't learn my lesson
not a lights on me camera action all the
lights on me some fluorescent
diamonds when i talk see it glisten
steady making noise never listen steady
paying dues counting blessings yeah
blowing on some dope never stressing got
the lights on me camera action all the
lights on me is fluorescent
[Music]
digital death let's get it
your intention was vibe out and have fun
it served this purpose bro i do think
that like i'm imagining your vocals on
the record and i feel like if you could
find a way that could even bring more of
that recorded sound into the live
performance it's true
[Music]
i told this boy i think he's sexy
figured he liked my energy before he
even met me pretty eyes i can only see
through pixels and i can even front
cause really i will show these nipples
in i don't like to waste time i just
like a great timing and sit on a
facetime so i think it's facetime facing
101 with a drink in between same eyes
and he's sweet but i know it's a dream
we took off in the park he kept up a
conversation then it started getting
dark i gave him an invitation to my
apartment complex and it's kind of
complex my brother in the next room i
don't want to alarm him uh i'm a sneaky
win
i'm a sneaky win
i'm a sneaky
like i love hearing that from a woman
perspective is too because i think it's
so normalized for men to be like talking
about their hookup stories and this or
that and like to be like yeah yeah i'm
sexual too
i think we should start off with who did
the best who do you guys think oh no
what do you think i'm gonna go with
jason yeah because i feel like the
performance was there in terms of like
lyricism addiction all that type of
i think that jason also uh is top two
the only thing i'll say is i think that
i'm number one and the reason i say that
is because of range you know be able to
have sounds that exist in completely
different you know spaces you know i
think rappers should be able to swag out
shamelessly and also be able to tell a
vulnerable story and my only thought for
you is that i wanted one of those to be
a lot more personal but i was like
what's jason choo's story right i'm kind
of the same way like i'll put myself on
number one because i felt like for me
personally like the range as well the
flows melodically on the cadences and
just just having fun and being personal
shoot man i know this is hard man we can
all be like what we think the number one
was but let's none of us can talk about
ourselves just because otherwise we're
all going to be number one
i think you're number one
all right
how about we just all say no hard
feelings
yeah yeah okay
let's go yeah where i'm at is myself
jason gianni and then
alpha and dead and the only reason i put
dead last i think it's fun but also you
know like in this tick-tock viral world
like that's the kind of music that i
hear all the time and for me it's just
doesn't feel you know unique that's
totally cool you know i was gonna put
charles number five so
one
two three four five actually musically
deb i will put you higher up because i
think your music is really fun that's
honestly that i like driving around to
these days but i think like i said it
don't necessarily translate to a live
performance the next thing i would say
y'all to me was very close because i
love the swagger and attitude but i do
think that the presence
right here your energy was a little more
subdued your energy and just how you
came alive in front of the camera uh
edged it for me i'm gonna go one
two
three
four
five i think jason's gotten two ones so
far so i'm gonna okay so i'll
i feel like it should go this way
i'll also be really really real i don't
care who thinks i'm number one i can be
number 100 number five i don't care i do
this all the time
is our music hitting people is our music
causing any cultural shift or are we
just sitting in the studio being like yo
look at my multi celebrate everybody
coming up there we go and i think
especially right now you don't got to be
miracle lyrical spiritual you could you
could be
going up on tick tock right and people
having fun and joy and love to that
that's beautiful so i just want to put
that up there find your audience
[Music]
in spot number five we have yeah
hey
i'm a bad
i'm cool with it these first four
did reverse i'm consistent
you know it's about finding your
audience context is everything when it
comes to preference we all got lanes
you know what i'm saying and maybe some
of our lanes overlapped with jubilee
maybe some of our lanes the venn diagram
is like completely
detached you know obviously there's
going to be people who don't like what
you do but just embrace what you have to
offer because i feel like that's what
the world needs you know let's go crazy
love you guys
peace
it's 11 am most of my fans still
sleeping
oh it's sunday is it sunday
nothing like you know my fans are not